♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THE GREAT
ONE MARK LEVIN COMING UP IN A
FEW MOMENTS, BUT FIRST, WE MADE
YOU A PROMISE, WE WILL NOT STOP
OUR QUEST IN TERMS OF
FINDING EQUAL JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NEW DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT, NEW
DOCUMENTS RELEASED BY THE DOJ
SHOW MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF
MUELLER’S TEAM, INCLUDING THE
PITBULL OF ROBERT MUELLER, THAT
WOULD BE ANDREW WEISSMANN,
ACTUALLY WIPED THEIR DEPARTMENT
PHONES CLEAN, LIKE HILLARY,
BEFORE TURNING THEM OVER TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
GET THIS, MANY OF THEM, THEY ALL
USED THE EXACT SAME SUSPICIOUS
EXCUSE, ENTERING THE WRONG
PASSWORDS TOO MANY TIMES.
GOT TO CLEAN IT, THEN.
FOR EXAMPLE, WISEMAN USED THE
PASSWORD EXCUSE FOR ONE DEVICE A
ACCIDENTALLY -- YOU MEAN, LIKE
WITH A CLOTH?
I WIPED ANOTHER ONE CLEAN.
ACCORDING TO THE DOCUMENTS, WELL
OVER A DOZEN DEVICES WERE WIPED
CLEAN, SO ASK YOURSELF, WHAT WAS
THE MUELLER TEAM HIDING?
WHAT ARE THE ODDS THEY WOULD ALL
FORGET THEIR PASSCODES AND I’LL
MAKE THE SAME STUPID MISTAKES?
DO YOU BELIEVE THEM?
I DON’T.
OF COURSE, RATHER THAN FOCUS ON
THOSE POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS, YOU HAVE A
COMPROMISED, CORRUPT,
CONVENTIONAL LIAR AND OF ADAM SC
ROLLING OUT MONTHS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
HE’S TROTTING OUT ANOTHER
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO IS CLAIMING
KEY INTELLIGENCE ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
WE KNOW THE SUB SOURCE OF STEELE
SAID THERE IS NONE.
WE KNOW COMEY WAS WARNED BEFORE
HE SIGNED THE FIRST OF THREE
WARRANTS, THERE IS NO THERE
THERE, DON’T TRUST THE DOSSIER
COME HILLARY PAY FOR IT, AND
STEELE HAS AN AGENDA.
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER SCHIFF
SHOWS, THIS ONE IS LIGHT ON
FACTS, HEAVY ON HYSTERIA, RAGE
AGAINST TRUMP, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYING THERE
COULD BE MORE CHARGES IN THE
DURHAM INVESTIGATION.
WHEN, PLEASE?
AND FRANKLY, IT IS TIME FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE FACTS MAKE THAT CLEAR,
EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING,
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
THERE IS THE PRESIDENT EARLIER
TODAY.
>> DURHAM, WHO IS A VERY, VERY
RESPECTED MAN, AND WE ARE GOING
TO SEE WHAT IT IS.
I CAN’T TELL YOU THAT.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS -- I CAN
TELL YOU THIS, MAINLINE, THEY CH
CAUGHT, THEY SPIED ON MY
CAMPAIGN.
NEVER IN HISTORY HAS THERE BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS, AND I
GUARANTEE, IF THE ROLES WERE
REVERSED, AND I WAS ON THE
DEMOCRAT SIDE, PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN JAIL AT THE VERY HIGHEST
LEVEL.
>> Sean: HERE WITH A REACTION
TO ALL OF THIS,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I’M GOING TO BE BLUNT.
I DON’T BELIEVE A WORD.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
I DO NOT BELIEVE HIM.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT
CHARGING PEOPLE FOR WHAT THEY
THEMSELVES MAY HAVE DONE HERE.
>> WELL, IF YOU CAN’T MANAGE
YOUR OWN PHONE, WHY SHOULD WE
TRUST YOU TO INVESTIGATE A
CRIME?
SO, I GUESS THEY JUST RAN OUT OF
HAMMERS AND BLEACH, BLEACHING
MATERIAL.
SO, THE QUESTION IS, DID THEY
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE?
DID THEY INTENTIONALLY DELETE
INFORMATION FROM THEIR PHONE
BECAUSE HOROWITZ WAS ON THE
CASE?
THAT IS THE QUESTION FOR DURHAM.
MY JOB AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS TO FIND
OUT HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI GOT
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE SO WRONG,
WHY THEY LIED TO THE FISA COURT
TO MAKE SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN, AS DO FUTURE PROSECUTIONS
I WOULD BE SHOCKED IF THE ONLY P
PROSECUTED IS SMITH.
>> Sean: LET’S STAY THERE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
MORE?
HOW HAS JAMES COMEY ESCAPED HERE
HERE?
HE SIGNED THREE WARRANTS, HE WAS
WARNED BEFORE THE FIRST ONE, THE
SUB SOURCE TOLD HIM THAT NONE OF
THIS IS REAL.
THEY ADMIT NOW, THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THE MEDIA MOB LIED.
MUELLER’S TEAM LIED, THEY NEVER
SHOULD HAVE HAD MUELLER EVEN
APPOINTED, SENATOR APPEARED WITH
A DRAG COUNTRY TO HELL.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
COMEY, McCABE, AND STRZOK, TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
HOROWITZ REPORT.
NONE OF THEM HAVE TESTIFIED
SINCE HOROWITZ RELEASED HIS
REPORT.
SO THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS TO GET
ANSWERS FOR THE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE BEEN ASKING ON THIS SHOW.
THEY MAY HAVE GOOD ANSWERS, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE ASKED THE
QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: OKAY, SO WHERE ARE WE
WITH THIS?
AND WHAT ABOUT THESE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS?
BECAUSE I THINK THEY OWE US
ANSWERS, THAT THEY ALL OH, MADE
PASSWORD ERRORS, SO NOW WE’RE
JUST GOING TO ERASE THE PHONE
COMPLETELY?
YOU MEAN, WITH A CLOTH, THAT
KIND OF CLEAN, BEACH BEACH BIT C
THAT KIND OF CLEAN?
>> WE CANNOT LIVE IN A
COUNTRY -- TRUMP RUSSIA, HOW
MANY AGENTS WERE INVOLVED IN
INVESTIGATING ALL THINGS TRUMP
AND RUSSIA, HOW MANY SUBPOENAS
ISSUED, LIVES TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN, THE QUESTION FOR ME, WAS
THERE A DOUBLE STANDARD HERE,
IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS TO ME THERE
WAS, BUT STAY TUNED, SEAN.
YOU THINK YOU ARE MAD ABOUT THE
PHONES BEING WIPED?
STAY TUNED.
WE’LL TALK TALKING ABOUT 10 OR
12 DAYS AND SEE IF THERE IS
SOMETHING ELSE YOU CAN GET MAD
ABOUT IT, JUST STAY TUNED.
>> Sean: I HATE WHEN YOU ARE
BASICALLY TELLING ME YOU KNOW
SOMETHING I DON’T KNOW.
I HATE THAT.
BY THE WAY, CONGRATS ON YOUR
CAMPAIGN.
YOU ARE DOING WELL, I SEE
BARBRA STREISAND AND ROSIE, AND
BY THE WAY, PEOPLE CAN GET ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION ON YOUR
WEBSITE?
>> YEAH, Lindsey Graham.com,
MY OPPONENT IS GOING TO RAISE
$75 MILLION FOR EVERY LIBERAL IN
THE COUNTRY, TRYING TO DEFEAT
ME, FIVE OR $10 GOES A LONG WAY,
WE HAVE TO KEEP THE SEAT.
>> Sean: I WAS TALKING MORE
BUT THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
BUT THAT’S OKAY.
BUT YOU’RE RIGHT, WE NEED
SOUTH CAROLINA --
>> IF I LOSE, YOU WILL NEVER
HEAR --
>> Sean: YEAH, NO THANK YOU.
>> IF THE REPUBLICANS LOSE THE